JANET CONRAD: So the
course is three hours long,
and it meets twice a week.
We also have one extra
meeting on Friday
that they can come
in if they want to.
And during that time, there
are very few lectures.
We start out at the beginning
with just a few lectures.
There's lectures on
how to give a talk.
lab safety, of course.
There is a set few
lectures at the beginning.
But after that, the
students immediately go out,
and they start working on
their different experiments.
And what I do is I go
around from group to group.
The lab groups are
always two people.
And so I go around
from group to group
and, most of the time, what
I do is ask them questions.
"What are you doing?"
is a good start.
And then from there,
they'll tell you
where their problems
are and so forth,
and you can help
them figure it out.
One of the things you're
teaching them, for example,
is how do you debug a
system, which by the way,
is the same for debugging
code as debugging hardware.
The approaches that you
take are exactly the same.
So that's what I
do actually when
I'm in the lab itself and
I'm coaching them along.
If they don't look like
they've actually tried,
I encourage them
to give it a try.
If they come up
with a question, we
talk a lot about how it is that
they might test the question
that they've thought of.
And so, that's the kind of thing
that I do in the lab itself.